[Music]
the rocket equation it's a beautiful
thing
no astronaut launches for space with
their fingers crossed that's not how we
deal with risk
[Music]
what i learned from 21 years as an
astronaut is that
the more you know the less you fear
the reason i wanted to do this master
class is to share
the hidden depths of purpose that are
behind space exploration
when the clock hits zero start focusing
and
thinking of nothing else but the moment
that you're in
study every system on a spaceship and
then boil it down
to what i call a one pager you've got to
be able to solve your problems in one
breath
[Music]
you have to push your lungs forward
through the drag of the atmosphere
crushed into your chair you're like a
leaf in a hurricane the reason is
one half rho v squared s 16 times the
speed of sound
as you accelerate harder and harder the
light blue florida sky
starts to get darker and darker and then
suddenly black
and the engine shut off and you're
weightless
turn the handle and open the hatch you
pull yourself out into the universe
and now suddenly when you move your
knees you can feel the searing heat of
the sun on one side and the incredibly
cold
emptiness of space on the other when
you're no longer earthlings
how do you navigate you can use the
stars
you can actually see how that place
where you were raised
fits into the overall complexity and
reality of the solar system
you start to unavoidably wonder
are we alone in the universe
or not
our technology is just good enough now
that some of you taking this master
class
are going to fly in space reusable
rocket ships
give us access to explore like we've
never had before
it will be a great moment of
introspection for humanity
if you're the person who finds that one
little fossilized flower
on mars i'm chris hadfield
and this is my master class
you